what I'm gonna talk to you about today
in this video you either gonna love some
of you gonna show my gosh what a great
concept I'm gonna share this with
everybody or you're not gonna like and
you're gonna stop the video and say I
don't like this guy and what he's saying
regardless of it if you listen to it all
it's gonna make you think let me explain
to you so you know how you work for
companies and the companies say you know
we offer benefit programs and this is
our benefit program and you say what are
they why don't we offer retirement plan
and we offer profit sharing when you hit
a certain director level you know we
offer health insurance of three hundred
fifty dollars and if you have kids and
you're married we offer this for your
kids and we do dental and you know we
also offer education if you go and we
pay for it and all these benefit
programs that companies offering all
while it's great if I work here this is
a great place and because a company
offers great benefit program retention
its high your for talent now this is the
part where it gets tricky you ready what
benefit do you offer to have a
relationship with you
let me ask that one more time what is
the benefit program of being a friend
with you or working with you or wanting
to get closer to you what's the benefit
you ready now you may say that's a
technical question there Pat I
understand it but what is it what is the
benefit program I was 24 years old
dating a girl I was forty-nine thousand
dollars in debt at the time made some
bad choices business-wise had and
checking account B of a of - 743 and
that's all I had to my name I parked my
car all over the place so for Galpin
couldn't come and repo my car my Ford
Expedition
i sat there one there so would you let
your daughter marry you
so not the 24 year old pad no way why
because what was the benefit program of
being with me I'm a logical enough to
know that I'm good with words maybe I
can get the girl to say oh why I like
this guy but I don't have a lot to offer
at that time make sense let me go to you
here what is the benefit of being a
friend with you what is it you may say
I'm a very good listener oh that's a
good thing it's good to be a listener
you know I'm very good with my diet I
exercise a lot okay so what do you mean
by that if we go to a restaurant and our
first to order you will generally be
pressured indirectly to order good
so if I order water with lemon you'll
also order water with lemon because in
your mind you're gonna say I was about
to order coke but you know what I gotta
watch my dad cuz summer's here I'll also
do water in lime if I do salad and
such-and-such and I'll say I want to
Italian light you may also want to go
with chicken breast and salad and go
Italian light because you're paying
attention to it so benefit of being
around me is you're gonna have a
healthier life okay cool it's another
benefit man if you're friends with me I
got I know a lot of haplotype girls tell
you right now I know how to party we're
gonna have a good time tonight
there's a benefit to it if that's what's
a priority if you're friends with me
you're gonna be a little bit
uncomfortable at times why because I am
so hungry about life and getting after
it
so you either gonna love it because it
also drives you to keep getting better
are you gonna hate it cuz you're gonna
say all this guy cares about as this
courier I'm so sick of it already you
know okay so what is the benefit program
you may say my contact I have access to
2.8 billion dollars of money if you want
to raise money I got the right
investment bankers I know I know the
right people would money so my mic might
- my contacts - my information I have a
my brain my knowledge you know faith
spiritual whatever it is it is a benefit
program so let me go even one layer
deeper than that so look at it this way
if people get closer to you do they win
and get improve their life we say one
more time if people get closer to you do
they do better in life so now you may
say of course they do
do you have a resume and how good is it
what I mean do I have a resume do you
have a list of names to say this person
came and when they first met me they
were only making this much money now
they're making that kind of money they
have a great personal life they're happy
their health is this that person was
this and then when they met me now
they're doing this and that and this
person now they're doing this and we
have a great friendship and we have a
relationship we hang out on Sundays they
pop into their kids birthday party and
when I knew this person and the
environment to this and here's what
happened to this and now we have
strengths because people around me
improve in their lives
do you have a list is there that list
now some of you may say para
don't have that list I'm only 27 years
old I know 27 year olds that have that
list I'm only 17 years old okay fine
now I understand out I also know 17
knows that are after it but the moral
the story here is who do you want to be
with the benefit program to the world
because I see a lot of businesses I'll
go to and if I go to them and say six
months later 12 months later I go visit
the business I'm like all the same faces
all same income level no one's killing
it everybody's about the same level
who's running this place who got it that
girls all about herself where that guy's
all about himself where those guys are
not working or they've already reached
plateaued and they're comfortable this
makes sense why nobody else is improving
this place is capped out I got it
because the benefit program that was
offered there's a cap to it so this is a
pressure type message to some of you
it's not the easiest message to listen
to and say I want everybody who works
for me to watch this this is the kind of
a message that you say I don't share
this with nobody this is a tough message
to share nobody I hope no one watches
Pat's video today of nobody watches
Pat's video today because these things I
think he's talking about me I think
here's the reality is I talked about
myself with this for years this message
isn't about you this message is me
myself asking a question saying what
benefit do you want to offer to the
world what benefit you want to offer to
your kids what benefit you want to offer
to your friends what benefit you want to
offer to your spouse what benefit you
want to offer to your family what
benefit you want to offer to your
heritage
what benefit you want to offer to your
industry what benefit you want to offer
to your nationality to the nation that
took you in America Patrick what benefit
do you want to offer huh what benefit do
you want to offer to these people what
is it
had a guy call me yesterday he sent me a
message saying I'm speaking to a crowd
of a thousand people to Montreal
everybody hears talking about that you
tamen do you mind making a video and
sending it to me I said of course I
didn't even think I was I was very busy
sent the video to him you know why send
a video to him because this guy
interviewed me for a job when I
was 21 years old I think he's like 5
years older than me 6 years older than
me I was so impressed by him I said I
have no desire to be in a business
you're in but I want a relationship with
you and a friendship with you
fast forward obviously you know he's
extremely successful as well he does
very well for himself but for me I told
them day one when he was way ahead of me
I said I guarantee you I'm also gonna
bring value to you because I'm not
selfish to come in and just take value
from you and not bring you back to you
it's very important to me to also give
you value because it's selfish if I
don't bring you value I want to also
bring you value that's how I feel I am
paying my debt for what you've given me
at a time that I have nothing to offer
you
does that make sense so again I don't
even know if you got the premise of
today's message I don't know if I did a
good job communicating the message to
you because I'm right in front of the
gym right now I had a pretty busy day
today with birthday party and kids and
all these different commitments but it's
a message I wanted to gift you it's a
Sunday today it's a message I wanted to
give you because this decision changed
my life when I stopped trying to get
everybody else to make my life better
and I started to realize how can I make
everybody else's life better just by the
benefits I offer to the world what he
wanted to be it went from here out not
from let me take from everybody from
Europe when I started going from here
out and I started looking on saying how
come your friends around you don't are
not doing better kind of a friend are
you
what is this is it just a
one-dimensional type of relationship now
I want everybody to be doing that I want
my dad my sister my wife my I want
anybody connected to me I want everybody
to know that guys my freakin friend that
guys my family he's got my back I am so
glad to have that guy's phone number on
speed dial and I know that guy's gonna
pick it up that's a benefit program
makes sense I don't care about 401ks
profit sharing all that other stuff all
that is fine
there's a lot more valuable things in
life than just that and if you can
figure out a way to help your peers
around you also make more money that's
even ten times better if you can do that
so take a sheet take a paper and pen out
and write out the benefits you offer to
the world and then if the list is not a
long list they make a list of benefits
you do want to offer to the world okay
then a second thing make a list of the
place you're working at how many new
people's lives have been changed not old
new people in the last six months twelve
months it's the same ol same ol
well maybe there's a problem where
you're at and that's got to change but
here's one thing for a fact results
never lies never does if the results are
good that's visible if it's not it's
also visible you can hide from it all
you want but until you face the truth
nothing's gonna change hopefully I made
sense to you today anyways have a killer
day and a killer week everybody take
care love you bye bye